instead of welcoming customers staff at
liquid Leisure water park were today
morning one laying flowers for the 11
year old girl who died yesterday
afternoon a traumatic experience for
those who are unable to save her
Emergency Services were called after the
girl disappeared while swimming she had
been with a group celebrating a friend's
birthday it took more than an hour to
find her after a search involving
helicopters before she was taken to
hospital where she died
Anna and her family were at the lake
with her brother-in-law who saw the
incident unfold my brother-in-law had
spotted that there was a girl that there
was a splash with a group of children
about 12
11 12 years old and one of the girls had
had a splash gone under and he was
alarmed that she hadn't he hadn't seen a
return to the surface of the water and
at that point he felt alarmed and he
looked across to the Lifeguard that was
on duty and she had already spotted it
and she went straight into the water
some staff reportedly borrowed customers
goggles so they could search the lake
which has a floating obstacle course
life jackets are required on it but not
in the beach area where the girl was
swimming a former employee who worked
here last summer putting in place
training and safety requirements has
told Sky News that no corners were ever
cut on safety and the staff received
monthly training on water rescue but he
also said that the depth of the water in
the lake can change dramatically
police are currently treating the death
as unexplained and have launched an
investigation in a statement they
praised those who tried to help this has
been an extremely traumatic and
upsetting incident for all involved I'm
aware that several members of the public
entered the lake shortly after the girl
got into difficulty but were unable to
locate her I would like to commend them
for their courage and their bravery
the water parks say they're assisting
police and that their thoughts with all
those affected her family is now being
supported by specialist officers after
what began as a celebration ended in
tragedy Ivor Bennett Sky News Windsor